but it was from someone named D lamb who
mentioned that the person who delivers
like I guess heating oil was that what
it was yeah she said they can't
guarantee the supply over the winter
yeah in the UK we heard the exact same
thing the BBC is secretly preparing
messages for when there's energy
shortages like blackouts or something
and they're saying they that there may
be rationing or shortages of fuel for
heating people's homes in the winter uh
mind you they said at the beginning of
December not only even to the Christmas
holiday so December yeah yeah you can
get well uh like upside down Planters
pots those clay pots and then you cut a
little hole in the top and you put
candles inside of them they create like
heat yeah like holds the Heat and then
makes like a like a little bit of you
know radiator and then you put like
layers of them so you put a larger
planter on top of a smaller planter and
you can get a lot of ambient heat for if
you don't have heat and also I don't
know how important it is but don't they
use diesel to transport diesel yes
diesel trucks
compounding compounding problem